are we any safer because of all the
regulation no in fact I would say the
opposite I commented very early on after
the bill was passed that it can't work
and we're going to cures in fact the way
I put it it was going to cause as much
problem as wage and price controls did
back in the 70s I think it's pretty much
online and the one area which I approve
of is it's significant increase in
capital requirements if it had stopped
there or even made the capital
requirements higher I think it would
have been a very effective bill but now
it is a mess it is very difficult to
convert the text of the legislation
which is essentially the government
telling the regulatory agencies to solve
such and such a problem it's very
difficult to implement such instructions
and I don't think this bill is working
at all and I would like to see it
repealed but I must admit that the
politics of such as that is called
wishful thinking well well let's be
wishful on I thinking promote it let's
assume you could repeal dodd-frank what
would you put in its place you said you
like the increased reserves how far
would you go well I would actually go
anywhere from 2 20 to 30% of assets for
pure equity now I know everybody says
well that's going to shrink the banking
system it will to a certain extent but
the extent that it is is for those loans
you shouldn't have made in the first
place
but if you go back historically you find
going all the way back to 1869 when the
first data were collected by the office
newly minted office of the controller of
the currency and we have annual data all
the way back for national commercial
banks and what those data show is that
the
she'll have net income two assets has
been remarkably stable between five and
ten percent and when it went off for a
year or two it came back very
dramatically but during that period we
had huge changes in the ratio of equity
to assets both up and down but that did
not change the rate of return so as far
as I can see if history is going to
repeat itself where it almost surely
will if we were to raise a regulatory
requirements on capital I don't care how
much you do it actually we will end up
with a far more stable system because
the problem is that basically the best
way you can describe why the markets
break down is that the Adams helped me
to figure out that's where putting this
are getting into technical issues but
what what we need to recognize is a
contagious default process out there
which unless we stop we're going to run
into all sorts of problems and what
dodd-frank has left us with is a system
in which contagious default can still
occur and if that is in fact the case
it's done nothing but if you have a high
enough ratio of equity to assets you get
there's no way you get contagious
defaults there are no contagious to
false in the non financial sector let us
speak of